sempre bello registrare video appena
svegli si vede proprio che vivo la mia
vita bene bene a tutti ragazzi benvenuto
che sono video sono fa vj e oggi vi
documento la giornata di ieri ho fatto
un sacco di cose quindi abbiamo
registrato un video io e giulia penn per
una sua serie che si chiama spaghetti e
musica riusciranno i pare lunedì sul
canale di giulia che vi lascio
descrizione vi lascio un'anteprima delle
cagate che sono uscite fuori quando
abbiamo registrato
[Musica]
se non volete ammazzando la zona guancia
7 cominciando con il tempo la moglie con
la mia cagna detrazione momento vinile
questo canile e se il momento venire
momento mimì portiamo in vinile
meraviglioso tracheali roma da piatto
intrattiene il pubblico ma da qui al
vinile con preparato per questa mia
da allora questo è il disco di lorenzo è
perché io quando canto bene mi metto
l'impegno non c'è per nessuno ragazzi ti
ami lorenzo 1994 twain ago non armata
l'anno dopo ma già sapevo mai cantato
bene quindi ho fatto pervenire prima io
gli dico tu sei scemo ap se la canzone
dove ci siamo limonate tagliarsi abbiamo
fatto quella scena del bacio solo 26
volte
dovevamo farci baciare i diversi punti
del di milano e voi adesso però chiedo
come è stato brani dai forse davanti
devi essere una persona onesta sincera
parla da sé che è stato bravo non solo
bravo e che siete continuava tutto
quello che vuoi ma no partita è stato
avrà un raro ma bravo e porro avanti in
modo da una palese fi borghese dei vari
location dai voto 10 10 alla rovescia il
bagno 10 10 10 10 10 10
abbiamo vissuto un sacco di esperienze
ti che insieme con summer festival c'è
stato sto basso tante vite dietro quel
bacio anche stupito vanno chiuse solo
perché ancora si ricorda che il bacio è
incredibile
fatele cliccate sui giornali e dopodichè
sono date il concerto di mattina
ma questa è piaciuto niente guardan
fai tu dol
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
lisa ciao
e asma scellato tanta bella gente
però io odio la gente
sì
j
il nostro
mi manca
all
cosa non è
sì copyright
gemma
la partita però binello
[Musica]
a monetizzare mi vedo margini stato c'è
nel senso non avevo bevuto ero così io
sono così di mio c'è qualche problema
secondo me sono tornato a casa
abbiamo giocato un po con google on io
mio amico siamo delle persone
intelligenti ogni tanto allora quando è
nato di allora mi piace far finta che
ogni giorno sia il tour compleanno alla
quando è nato il portiere marzo 1909
quando è nato attuale è di allora
wikipedia per esempio agostino al 100 le
date del 25 sociali quando le dee
canciano crescere giovanni in acqua
quando è nato ad un lay e di alloggio
per la date le 25 dicembre con prove di
uno slogan e cori top sto mentana oggi
vitol di cui 8 né a quel quadro giorni
cominciano a crescere poi anche a cristo
la natura cominciate crescere questo
giorno a cominciare dal quale la luce
del giorno aumento asca tempo fa oggi a
milano stanno terminando le previsioni
127 gradi e cielo parzialmente nuvoloso
però c'è dai rimedi posizione la cosa
più vicina che abbiamo avuto dall'inizio
qual è il vero nome di favi j
mi dispiace è il google
chi è il padre di famiglia il padre di
famiglia sergio studi
non dire che possiamo concludere qui è
un prossimo concerto un po più normali
magari speriamo non mi abbiano copyright
atto il video dove i ragazzi si sa dove
è piaciuto questo momento mi piace anche
da questi ti schieri ci vediamo alle
persone dai ragazzi sono gabriele ciao
non ho capito ciao ciao lorenzo alzò
lorenzo gabriele
[Musica]